Don't worry my call big homie Big Homie
Excuse me
It's
We needed to checkStatus. One by one.
As soon as it sees that the status of One
agent is all it should send it to that agent
then resume checking the next agent we
should not try to send all the resume
prompts at once
That makes the message you go crazy
Situation
To see
You again
Thank you
You're so far doing nothing again well all
right man I mean it comes right back in
again it's great Futures straight that I
have here in the course
Period
It wasn't said right now
Looks like
Everybody
Over here
Into a lot of videos
What's up boss man
Thank you Google yeah
You got a cigarette too no rush no rush I
got this one
That's fineEyebrow smoke.
Thank you boss manNancy. I just didn't see
it.
Disappear toGone.
In Minecraft
Boom
Come on you think it's going to be like that
todayEven though all that yesterday.
I'm prepared
Even for the worst even though the teacher
ain't called cuz sometimes she don't call
and he still happy
Thinking he doing good and you get up
thereSo. Bad.
Even though chicken want me to have lunch
And I said Daddy
What's upWhy what happened.
Ultrasound
Different methods of looking at the same
stuffYou know.
She found something
Why does it keep coming backWhy is it coming
back I thought they got rid of it.
Is there another doctor or something you
know I'm starting to doubt her ability to be
able to do this
Is there another doctor or something you can
talk toCuz I don't want him just poking
around just cuz like you're a test subject.
YeahI get that. I get that but I'm just
saying like we are we just been through
this.
And now it's coming back so it's like it's
got me questioning did y'all do it right the
first time like what is this
Where you you have to do that too
Still don't like itI hear you.
I hear you they're saying that this is
normal but I'm saying it's just weird when I
go see a doctor and the problem solved if I
take all the pills you tell me to take
I'm not supposed to be sick no more
So then then not just that but then like
even how she's explaining it sounds weird
and I understand that you're probably just
relaying the best memory of the things that
she said but when my doctor said I felt
something and you can't give me a scientific
term for what you felt
I thought they stuck a whole camera inside
you
I'm sorry I'm just frustrated
And what did they say about the samples they
took
Like I said it's not I'm just frustrated at
the situation not not nothing her
specifically I just really don't like
hospitals I really don't like like I feel
like it's a scam and then when I hear stuff
like this it sound like they just trying to
get you to go back to pay for the expensive
CAT scan like
I just don't understand why they couldn't
have figured it out while they were already
in there or why she didn't grab samples of
the stuff while she was already in there
NoOr if you have I missed it but I hear you
now.
Have you been doing thatIs it better.
Okay
At least that's something that we're used to
you having
Cuz from my recollection you have been
dealing with this hernia for longer than you
have been dealing with carpal tunnel
The meshThat mess that they put in there.
Man seeIt's so hard messing with the
hospital industry.
Well if you come through here
And how's your head about this is it I say
how's your head about this when I hear it it
instantly frustrates me instantly just shit
sends anger down my spine I start wanting to
take it off on the doctors even though I
know it's just life I just it's how I react
to it how are you dealing with all this
I will take that over chemo
Okay that's good that's good so we need to
immediately find out what this weird thing
is then
Cuz now I ain't going to be able to sit
straight
And that's the stomach
Right
No but this is definitely interest on
definitely interested in this one cuz I like
I said I deal with
I deal with stomach problems so like this is
this is possibly my future no luck
Yes
Question this is in the family of ulcer
heartburn
Okay never mind then this is cuz you over
stretched or lifted him properly growing up
Pulling and straining I get it I get itJust
asking I was just asking.
The crazy thing about that is the
The crazy part about that is growing up you
don't care right like I'm talking about
bending over making sure you lifting with
your knees not your back
But the older I get the more important I
find that to be
Just like even standing straight now that I
stand for a long time like I realize how bad
it is to stand with bad posture
Situation as far as I look up
Pasta while sitting or Pastor while standing
Cuz you're leaning like you're leaning like
a reclining chair
But they want you
And that's what they wantOkay.
You better sleep right now baby girl is
A baby girl's not here right now she's at
her cousin well she's at car she's with
Carmen's family
It's always cool having a house to myself
for like the first 30 minutes then after
that I don't do nothing but miss them till I
get back
I understand
What time you going to be doneOkay so you
cannot leave.
I ain't going to lie
When the girls gone are you goodThere's only
$13 for a Patty milk.
I can eat that twice
That'll carry me all day and all I need is
that and if I if I if I moving around a lot
of what not I might have to get breakfast
but
That's a dollar $2
So in total all day I'm spending 15 if I
want to get Whataburger while Aria and
Carmen's here it cost me no less than $30
And I don't even get a burger like like I
eat a piece of their burger and some of
their fries and it cost me $30
It's just crazy to me
Cuz I know that was your biggest worry
He was able to get that deep breath
Oh okay
What what we can't do is we can't worry
about itYou know.
Right
All the way out there I don't even know
I'm here
Okay
Could you send on December my doctor just
said Dr Tom said that my her gastritis
DancingDecember 10th.
Now I should have told her to put it in
rightNow.
Abdominal
I say all that was a mouthful
I can't do nothing I can't
Feeling my right shoulder right now
And it's going to take 30 days
I'm just history
I actually don't
I do believe it I mean I do because think
about all the time you've been through the
hospital in 60 years
And then the Marine Corps however they
manage to scrape all that together and put
it in one box
But they said 12,000 pages
Yeah I think that's crazy but you know what
because they got to Define stuff so specific
It probably isAbout 12,000 pages is crazy
how small are the pages.
Right right
For a copy of paper book by boxOf copying
paper.
OkayNo I think one is 500 dad.
Okay okay okay okay okay I believe it I
believe it
Two boxes for the pages but to see but but
look but look cuz the way they do the labs
Dad they might put one thing on the page
Right but they probably could have fit that
on a half a page if they put it all together
Right if they kept all that every single
time yeah yeah no no list no less no less
Cuz I I done got one of those little package
just from a prescription it was like 10
pages and all I was supposed to do is take a
pill just three times a day
Yeah I think she just threw a big number out
there to let you know it's a lot
Is it possible for you to request that like
could you go in and look at all that
I'm not saying you could you would I'm just
saying could you if you wanted to
Cuz I believe that is aI think that's an
opportunity for AI if it hasn't already been
touched.
Like to have a AR read all those documents
sort out all the instructions and just put
them to the side we just
KnowNo that's incorrect A eyes improved to
where you can write a note.
And AI can read it
Yes sir yes sir it's not but the thing is
it's not always perfect so it's not
consistent
Marine CorpsTo. P a m.
PortlandArkansas.
Pull up my exam from that I had back at 2020
The information out there from 1986
That's missingFrom VA. Okay. Okay.
I'mma watch a couple of defcons learn some
code and stuff and get really deep into that
South Park new loveseat newChair. Because if
they got. That's what.
I see all that much and I found
Out I was more comfortable City on the love
seat than I am sitting on the sofa if you
get rid of your couches and stuff don't just
set them outside I will come and pick them
up
Cuz your old ones last to me this long you
know what I'm saying but not that but these
these days they too much now like they're
done
They're losing the Integrity of the chair
Yeah but see
I don't get income taxes like everybody else
that would be my main method of doing it I
got to get to a little comfortable before I
could
I ain't going to lie I could really afford
it if I really really wanted to
But I didn't get it until I live by myself
I'm not paying for new furniture cuz like
I'm even looking at how to cap ripping up
the sides of this couch
I hate itYou know what I'm talking about
that little stuff where they call the claws.
And I don't understand that they're like
that little stuff really I don't got no
picsBut I'm dealing with pets you know what
I mean.
The dog outside in the back entertainment
but you know I can't do nothing about that I
just wish she would just go to the grass so
we don't got to look at it
No I don't I use mom I'll use my washing
Yes washer and dry up there at the place the
washer needs to be repaired
They done came in over used it and broke the
spring that hold it from shaking and bacon
And nobody wants to pay for it so then I'm
completely happy with them thinking it
doesn't work cuz they can't figure it out
Oh yeah ofOh yeah of course. Not I'm going
to sit here or no not at all.
Yeah they got one they got one and they even
bought another one but then the people that
came in to put the stuff wasn't able to put
it in and I'm not going to help move my
stuff out when I feel like they should have
just fixed my stuff instead of got a whole
new washer but you know that's neither here
nor there I told him they can move it if
they want it
But I'm not helping
Mine is still hooked up theirs is outside in
the garage
That I got a laundry area
It's upstairs like right after you come up
the steps
And I don't blame you at this point I don't
go upstairs I don't really know what it look
like up there
I feel like that's probably bestCuz I
struggle with keeping downstairs good.
And nobody but me is down here
supposedlySupposably.
Oh I know when I'm cleaning up cuz you know
you know what you messed up
What I don't know is
Who randomly messed up and and sometimes it
what I do is I'll just say it's the kids
I'll just assume it's the kids cuz I know
I'm only got a bunch of kids so I just clean
it but not the kids
No it ain't no no no cuz I just I'm slowly
making my way through cleaning up making
sure everything straight but after I clean
it I'm not cleaning
Like you get the one free because I didn't
know
But I know what I ate off of you know what
I'm saying like I know I know where I've
been I'm only at my computer so I shouldn't
have to clean up anywhere else but the
computer
But for the I am so I once again I do not
know I'm not saying they are I haven't come
up into any problems thus far and you know
they've been gone for 3 days so right now
maybe it is the kids but I just you know
time will tell
All the way down there when
You got to come down here and stay with us
then
No really
And start looking into how much that's going
to costOh Life is Beautiful.
I want you
To wake up tomorrow look in the mirror and
smile at yourself at the good decisions you
made in your life just one time for me okay
when you wake up in the morning and you
feeling all grogging right now go look in
the mirror me like you know what he was
right
I did do pretty damn good
Job
A record
Know about the army of the Navy but I know
the Marine Corps used to take probation
He said I don't know where to come over this
story about the court of the judge said you
are no
Those pictures
For the position
Living I'm supposed to be living the best
that's lifeThe only thing that's listening.
Is.
No don't say that
To get her sir
Wrong
Are you okay
No it's not even cold over hereOver here.
Oh I was like no no no no
46° tonight sounds like a good opportunity
to
Hi babe
Yeah yeah
HereBut that was enough.
You know
Trying to quit again
It's just out of habit you would
continueThat's how I feel about cigarettes.
You know because I knew that I knew the
doctor was going to be checking my private
area
This is prescribed
Right he said that's why you wanted her to
see the diaper I was saying that
If I do if validates my plane that I can't
hold you
For the
For when that happens
No that's actually I would prefer that
Cuz I would prefer that over having to go
out to get them myself
I'm looking for
I donate them to a Goodwill and there was a
lot
15 notches
15 bucks
You knowThat's not that bad.
That's why I said that's not bad cuz I'm
just thinking of how much like diapers cost
like
Just in general
You said one for what yeah cuz you're saying
a dollar each
Song
Brother as long as that as long enough to me
Right so then shoot I wouldn't even
I just put a couple of pieces of wood on the
fireplace on
Chicken noodles in the freezer
Yeah and that's actually I'm doing good on
food right now too
Yeah we just got like we just got some
groceries andYou know fridge is actually
full on everybody's in.
I know right if that wasn't hard that's what
Yeah I'm still here like whenever you want
to talk I might available I ain't doing
nothing I'm just going to be coding
?Yeah that's cuz I was walking to the
Whataburger when you come.
NothingYeah it ain't that far I just wanted
to walk.
I mean I do need to be taking it easy on the
truck until I get that piece fixed up
Nah I still ain't pressed that out here
Anyways I'll talk to you later I love you
love you too bye dad
What's up man
Yeah you called Mama
And what's up shorty how you been
Me tooAnd that's going to cost like.
We didBut.
No I did but he couldn't find it I couldn't
find it we couldn't find it and so now
I got that long ass trip on the truck
without fixing the problem
That's that's badCuz all those miles is like
the free miles the car was giving me while I
got this problem.
And you only got so much like think of it
like a little wind up to it
That's what it's going to come to but first
I got to stop being stupid with my
moneySounds like how you been.
Hey but I don't know I got multiple people
telling me different things cuz the car is
messing the holes that supposed to filter
the air
I got upstairs that put my fans on cuz I got
both the fans on but we accept them let it
run and it was still the temperature be a
thermostat
So he was like maybe it's the thermostat but
He he just going through the checklist
that's how they do those kind of things you
can't be mad at him
Delicious cost me more I know
And I still gotTo pay a car still got to pay
the insurance.
Company
Just get it from my baby mama
And I had talked to her baby like the second
or third about the food stamp but she's like
what Mom said on a lion so I've been waiting
and trying to hold off on spending money on
food too she told me they cut her off
So I don't knowThat's another thing so I got
to figure out food.
And I don't know hopefully I can
The other guy working on the car he said
that he got the thermostat but he supposed
to be coming to put it on so hopefully
That works so I can at least start saving
the money all over and just drive myself to
work at home
I hope cuz that if if so then things get a
little bit easier right
1314Every day is crazy.
No I definitely get that especially when you
got a car outside bro
Because it's like bro I could have threw
that in my tank and been good like all week
But how's the kids
The place like Garden 36 minutes
So you couldn't go cuzLife Is Life and it be
like that sometimes.
I get it
But you say he's been doing good in school
So she all I'm sayingThat's a blessing.
Cuz you could also be dealing with you know
them calling you up from school while you're
at work trying to get the money
And I'm not being funny I'm just being
grateful cuz I know how she gets
Oh Lord hide in the paperThat was me.
I got my ass and I got my I got me and Kiki
ass up
For the teacher text me the next day like
hey I found a marriage paper headed
Black boyIt's only one reason.
Tell me why
Is a perfectionist
If you had a good dayCuz I.
Okay
Oh shitWho's a big boy.
She'll get it
Figured out
One day I will
Come
So how's it like well we need to find a
place to move your voucher to so you don't
lose it on my fuck like how am I supposed to
lose what I have possibly eviction on me
And it's not even my fault but I don't know
how to move forward with that
IfI don't know I just don't know at this
point.
I'm going to go because
Nothing but a house or something
Place
So whatWas the moving lessons like what do
you do.
WellDon't stress.
Everything
Please give me a call backOkay.
But he ain't never answer the phone so to do
then of course the apartment lady
Upgrade so if I want the main thing to this
Channel fire space like if it's good
With anything like there's no way she is
like they have to fix themTomorrow.
It's messed up like it's supposed to be
electrical at least 10 years electrical and
they don't have those
Okay okay
Your
And I still will have to move and still have
an eviction on Monday
SoI don't know. We'll see I guess.
It's okay
What did you end up calling me for anyway
Ooh tell me about that I love to hear
Fastest way to like just put something out
there
I think that would be an amazing idea
especially since I have access to so many
kids
Because like in my mind it's like right a
little book and get a kid to read it put it
on YouTube
Sell itLike it sounds so simple right.
If it could build up because not only could
you have to sell it or you could sell it I
just found Amazon I guess they can start
small but if you put into
You know throw up in Barnes and Nobles or
other bookstores
So they can actually get payment for them to
hold it in their store
But I'll be the ideal Bank
Give me one second
All right I'm backHad to get along done I
apologize.
I reached outAnd I've been reaching out to
people to get.
IdeasWhat you say.
Give me one second my dad's callingHello.
Yes sirNo sir.
That is a lot of money
Just cuz you never know
Everybody in my bank account Swift and long
family will have to getYou a million
dollars.
And because I know it ain't no fall out of
200 I'm drivingRight.
And I'm doing a smooth 10,000 each
You know cuz that's a lot of money still
Right right and that's why I do it
I would have in my mind each person will get
a hundred thousand and I would only give you
10,000 chunks and each time I did it I would
tell you that that was all I was giving you
until you got to 100,000 and then that would
be really it
Even need $100,000 don't keep trying coming
back to meAnything.
2 million * 30 million you know
If you put yourself
Okay
All right no I hear you
I'm back I'm sorry it's cuz my dad was
calling
AnywayI was just saying. I'm basically at a
point where.
I'm reaching out cuz I want to
collaborateLike I realize now that.
I realize now that people don't want to do
stuff
Right and a lot of people say that they do
want to do stuff but they don't
But the real cool thing about it is
everybody has amazing ideasSo.
What
What my my plans are is to turn myself into
like the Workhorse rightSo.
I am willing to do the work right so
especially because we got AI right
What my hopes is thatThat I can create
products.
And then get people to
Thoroughly test the idea so that
It's actually a good idea if that makes
sense so like when we say
Let's make a children's book right
I'll go to Ai and all with that up in 20
minutes like I will literally whip up this
book in 20 minutes
Minutes and then come back and ask you to
read it
You said I'm saying and and that's very
possible but then the the hard part is
Getting it out there because I'm not willing
to Market things that is where I fall short
I'm not I'm not even good at reaching out to
people to tell them hey I'll do this for you
if you Market it for me like you know what
I'm saying like like
How do you go about putting a book on Amazon
but I know it's possible you just got to do
the research on which way to go about it
And that'sIt.
Here
He saw the phone like 4K but he's going to
put a royalties on there for like
She said 53% of the world too but he also
Amazon
No I love it I love it when that happens I
met some pretty cool drivers on Uber
And that but that be the thing though so
In my team right what I'm the first person I
need in my team or on my team is somebody
that is good at marketing right and
I'm down for likeActually doing a thing and
putting money behind it.
SoSo. I can't hear you.
But that that be the problem though I don't
know if even like I don't even know if even
you're serious right cuz like I say
everybody says they want something until
it's time to put the work in and I would
consider
For me even theEven the coming like I'm only
using.
Thermostat
I'm only using this as your example because
it's your example when it comes to yours per
se
When it comes to yours per se I like yours
because it's a low barrier to entry
I like yours because it's something we can
actually do and it's not hard
The only thing I don't like about yours is I
don't know how to Market it and actually
sell it
RightIf we had somebody or.
If we had someone on our team that was good
at thatThen we would be good to go.
But I don't know people do you know people
No that's that's the move hey that's the
move and she's already close to you so what
I'm telling you is that you need to knock on
that door right if you want to progress this
idea because like the next time well well
first we need to come up with an idea of
what you would like the first book to be
about right cuz I mean I can come up with an
idea don't get it twisted I promise to God I
could but I want this to be your book right
and I want you to like the book and when we
do then you could easily talk to Kelsey
right and then you can have her tell you
about the ads and shit and how she's
operating on Facebook and how that works
You know and even if we don't have the
product it doesn't stop you from having the
conversation next time you are talking where
you pick up that nugget like hey you're
running on Facebook I was thinking about
doing some stuff and trying to
And trying to sell stuff because remember
everybody around you wants to see you do
better
On her family to do the
This Christmas payroll has been doing that
since it is to be a better year so
So I'll see what I'm doing and all that so
Thank you for something right here
In the snow rush like I said we can
We can move at the pace of life cuz we have
a long time but I do want to make progress
and so every time we talk I'm just going to
be slowly trying to push that nerd right
like
This company no paper ads or whatever so it
can be posted
So I don't know if she just does it freely
or if you stay in like a special
Thing to post her becauseYou got an Android
phone right.
Oh I can hook you the heck up you need to
tell me like the things you need bro I'm an
AB developer I can make you apps you're on
an Android
Like I can make you ABS I don't know how
else
Making money how
Know that's not an idea what the hell
Just for you
Let's go see what AI says okay
Hey I want to make an Android app
Where I make money on thatYeah.
Give meGive me ideas.
All right they got wait no no no no no no no
no no no no it's it's this night
This is not it it's trying to make me making
that to make money no no no noStop. No.
I want to make money on the app
Not with the app
Yeah yeah yeah no nobody wants a micro
courseNobody want to.
What is thisThey don't got nothing it's
impossible.
I can make a reseller assistant
It'll just be something to help you spot
deals while you're out probably something
like Barcode Scanner it'd be one of those
same little things man I don't know
These ideas it just seems so hard to make
money out of thin air bro it's like either
get a job or you're screwed
I meanI'm just looking at these and they're
just as.
I'll read them I guess they got a small
business to a kid invoice quote client and
take for your own usage
They got study pack stores selling exams
content create all of these are ass bro
I'm in fact I'm just going to say that all
these are assI want like.
I don't even know what I wanted
Okay okay
It's cuz we don't have a good enough idea we
just need a better idea
It gave us the ideas that
I don't know I want to say just
Tell you
Until theHow do I get stories and.
Trying to teach people how to code that you
can put your ass for folding class or
This not for me for me what I know what I
want to do
I want toI want to do this.
Right like I want to take people's ideasAnd
turn them into real things.
And hopefully inspire people to like
actually do something with it
Right and then over time
Over time what I hope to develop is
Partnerships that I can Leverage
To help other people right and then I'm
hoping that that snowballs to become like
A small business incubator
So I'll have a marketing guy and I'll come
up to somebody with a good idea right and
then like cuz imagine we knew Kelsey and she
was just marketing and it's not even that I
don't know nothing about marketing I know
about Facebook ads
Right I used to do that and I got a thousand
followers on Free Ride investor right but my
question my question Still Remains like what
is she doing because she might know
something I don't
Like what without a doubt she knows
And I want to know what that is
Shit it because she's on that doing because
she's doing something I want her on the team
I want to see how you can get her to help
you do the book with us
Cuz the more the merrier the more eyes the
more hands the more the faster we'll get it
done and the better it'll be cuz I know who
I am and what I bring
And I Know Who You Are
And what you bring and Kelsey's about cuz
she's gang gang so that means she
automatically good
Plus she dealt with you this long anybody
that can deal with you this long she dealt
with you this long and she don't got kids
with you that right there that right there
That right there make her an amazing person
cuz you could be very difficult at times
It does not change the fact that you are
difficult
And that's cool though because that's you
though I'm difficult too though
Oh yeah oh yeah everybody come with that
shit
Shit in factIn fact.
Did win dealing with my ass you got to deal
with
You got to deal with like female ass shit
with my ass cuz I get mad at you and then
get mad that you don't know why I'm mad at
you
My bank of
Independence
30 seconds
And then even then I need to figure out what
happens once I get
Even a group of people right like what
happens after we get the book and we I mean
I would still even cuz I'm down to even do
like little micro experience experiments
just to see if we can get something
For more water
No water through is it going to need all
that water
Like I said I'm chilling
Like
I was a business major with a marketing
background
I'm three classes
I'm three classes away yeah no don't get it
twisted like but but see my problem is
I don't respect my degree cuz I I cheated
I cheated all through collegeAll through
college.
Jacksonville was a thing yeah I was a thingI
might have done.
Nah nah and I was in it at a good time too
like before they had to detectors and shit
Yeah they got a eye detectors now I was in I
was in school before they had that shit now
what they do to get you on the test is they
make the test so fast
So that it's likeYou even.
Yeah you either and you either know the
stuff or you don't
And that's the thing yeah I like it anyway
cuz like they don't do long
What it made what it did is it made the
colleges
What it did is it made the colleges like
require you to do more essays so that they
can like prove your writing style
But even then if you're good you could still
get AI to do it but as long as it takes to
get AI to do it you might as well just do it
yourself then give it to AI which is the
move anyway
Like you just you just free right the
question like I mean you free write your
answer and when you run out hand it all the
chat gbt to finish it
That's your that's your shitYou did that
like they can't take that from you.
Which is way easier cuz back in the day you
know you have to know all the punctuation
and where all the punctuation goes and all
nope you don't have to no more
No really it's almost like when you when you
think about it at this point right now right
now it's almost sad if we don't go get our
degrees because it's so easy right now
It is they give you the test right and then
they'll get like online at least the only
for online they'll give you the test and
then they'll even give you like two or three
tries at certain tests right so during the
first test like for me specifically me I'm
talking about me if if I see all the
questions one time
And the answer to sad question I'm not going
to miss that question again so if you ever
give me two questions two tests back to back
Which you can take the test back to back
And then show me the answers I'm sorry I'm
I'm a student I don't need you at GPT for
that
My problems be the essays cuz I'm not I'm so
lazy I don't want to put a 50-word response
Cuz you got to put a 50 word response for
two commentsFor every assignment.
And that's not really much we talking about
like four comments a week
But do you see how often I post on
FacebookI'll be commenting on people shit.
Now you asking me to comment on but I ain't
even write my own shit now you want me to
read yours
I was giving that to Chad gbt too glad
Hey Siri hey hey your boy got like a 2.7 GPA
No no no no no noNo no no no that's it. I
still.
I still think it's all me cuz at the end of
the day when I tell you that you had to
You don't want it to look like it's AI so
you're sitting in there editing and making
sure and I ain't get caught so I did a good
job like obviously if you're stupid they
catch you I'm not stupid they didn't catch
me
Thank God for the tax test though no
bullshit I didn't know commending on the tax
test meant that I didn't have to take that
little pre college exam like I could just go
and start classes
They should have told me that a long time
ago and I really
I guess the only thing stopping me from
getting a degreeIs I want to go get
certified.
I just want to go get certified in codeine
cuzI'm good enough already.
And I know that cuz I was reaching out to
developers and I'm watching and working and
looking at their projects and a lot of these
people right are only working on the project
right like they're so they're specialized in
their project right so I was talking to a
guy and he built a game right and he was
talking about how he he made it
He was making a game that had like mahjong
tiles you ever heard of my John's house
It's that little Chinese game where they
stack up all the little Chinese towels and
you got to click the matches
But you can't click the ones that are
underneath certain ones or something like
that
He was playing he was making a game like
that and like chess and checkers and I was
talking to him about how me and Aria are
creating a chess at where we're having an AI
coach right and that's Aria is leading that
project I'd like to repeat that you know I
have a daughter named Ariel who's 13 who's
working on a similar project that this you
know 30 year old man's working on
Cool right and that's all he's working on
All right that's that and then I was talking
to another guy who was working on a crypto
experiment who he was no he he wanted to
He wanted to work on a crypto experiment but
I don't have to go through the list of all
of them but pretty much all these guys were
working on one little thing and no offense
to them right but I have completed projects
that represent each one of these things
right and they're all under my belt like I
can talk to these guys about all these
different domains that's what let me know
LikeMy shit don't stand. And I can talk my
shit.
So now I just want to get the certifications
cuz once I get the certifications then you
really can't say nothing and I don't got to
go to college to go get them I just got to
be willing to put down the bread to say all
right I'm going to go take this test
And I know what the fuck I'm talking about
And that's that's going to be the move for
me I ain't even a lie to you cuz I'm not
down for this college stuff and it only
takes a few certifications to be able to get
me in the room with the people I need to
talk to to go land me a job making $150,000
a year
I don't need a couple of cut certifications
cuz my GitHub is my my GitHub and my
LinkedIn profile is going to be my resume
I got to make a whole new GitHub though cuz
the Swarm done got me fucking banned and oh
and and what I was telling you about like
when I was telling that little having the
agents work by themselves like how right now
right I've been talking to you this whole
time my agents have been sitting there just
working cuz I got the system going non-stop
it's 24/7
Nobody else got that like I'm the only one
Nobody is even
You know hey hey I did tell you I wanted to
be the Soulja Boy and charging me tea I said
that shit right was you here for that was
you here for that tell me you was here for
that that was a long time ago oh my gosh
If you was here for that oh my God I'm so
proud of you salute
If you was just saying that to fuck with me
then fuck you and drill
Something forGood choice good choice.
I'm hoping I make good choices in life
memeThinking about that with my dad.
Yeah manNah just I'm talking about just in
general like.
I hope because I'm thinking about him like
he's retired now he's able to retire right
E63That's 2 years early.
Yeah so so he's retiring early
I consider that successful
Yeah
Yes
And come back oh Lord
You said you got both the painGirl if you
got everything.
If you got everything then you Gucci
Oh Lord
So why you driving the car
Ibbean say the name of the piece again
Air and tables and the resonator we
missingThe air intake hose.
And a resonatorHose. Or tube.
What does that mean
OkayOkay.
You don't care
All right this is the main the air intake
hose is the main tube that carries clean air
from the air filter box to the engine often
to the throttle body
Okay I know where that is I don't have to
replace a couple of those
If it's missing or not till the engine May
suck in unfiltered air youYou get huh.
What you say
The engine May suck in unfiltered air which
is bad for long term engine wear
You get a rough idle hesitation and reduce
power possibly a check engine light and
codes that like lean condition or air flow
related codes
OkayThe resonator is but basically a noise
control chamber connected to the intake.
Its job is to reduce the intake drone and
smooth airflow
If that hose is missing the car may sound
louder or more wooshy when you accelerate
So it don't really matter that much
Yeah of course of course
See what the peace look like cuz I didn't
knowAnd another guy.
Told him to check it for me because they say
he works on everybody
Was too short for what and then I have to
look more and that's how I know that it's a
resonator too
I already looked it up on I know AutoZone I
can get it from AutoZone they like the two
different one pieces like 15 $16 of ones
like 22
Minutes
And we'll just put that to a credit on your
account
And Grill things are getting better
It only takes time
$5 and pay for a lift I can take them here
to his appointment but I'm going to get that
hoes and two things next week cuz that's
when I get paid again
But I'm still composed of our pants like if
I should pay my portion or just save my
money
AboutThe population.
Because I have to pay my portion of my rent
and still getting baked and then
Still have to go to the process with housing
Having to wait for a place to pass
inspection find a new place that has an
opening that accepts my voucher
Of money deposit an application fees
Just the weighted process like even if I do
get a big dick and I still get myHouse in
like I still have to get out that apartment.
So I'll have to wait
You know or apartment to come up for my
application to go through in front of the
approved for housing to approve it
Cuz it's against it's against housing law
like you can't move in a place before they
have inspection you can lose your house so I
can't even move there
They accept me and I pay my deposit I still
got to wait on house to be like okay we
going to check out this unit to make sure
that it past the inspection
All right it passed you can now move into
your unit
One 1231 I'm calling them like what's up
hello
Question mark
Now you got to be happy now you can start
putting antifreeze back in
Through
So what you're going to do when you get home
It's so what you going to do when you get
home
I don't know what I'm going to doOh Lord.
Hear
So everything she lives she didn't ask me to
go over there and check on her apartment
make sure that they you know keep the stuff
together
So that's probably the one personJust to
make sure.
My God this warm changed
Omaha that's going to work out with the kids
and pull away it's going to change anyways
since I have to move they probably
Somebody wants the same school but
At least I get the register all three of our
kids that's another question like all three
of the kids are finally in school since the
sorry birthday just passed before he's old
enough to go to pre-k
That takes care of like partial day here
Yeah it went out for a second but it's back
I never get an income tax ever since I was
married I've been never getting income taxes
I'm not divorced yet
No
You you know how to do that stuff you want
to fill out some forms for me
I don't knowI'm just playing I'm just
playing I'm just playing.
I don't know I was more serious back then
and I had a woman to fucking make me be on
my shit but now that I don't have anybody
telling me what to do
But now that I don't have nobody telling me
what to doI can do what I want. I know.
I actually know that
So I'm avoided and I'm lucky because you
know I'm not in a public setting so nobody
to sneak up on me and try and accidentally
make me fall in love and shit
Cuz I don't know if that's what I want
Rihanna I'm going to use it for
Almost okay I'm all done for thisBecause
I'm.
Just I don't know I'm just
As soon
And I need to air outOh yeah.
You mean
Yeah I know that's why I said that's
I'm not in my feelings anymore AndrewI can
honestly say I'm not.
I can honestly say I'm not in my feelingsI
can honestly say I'm not in my. Hello.
I can honestly say I'm not inMy feelings
though I just. I just don't.
I can download tomorrow
I don't know like
S
I was saying I don't
I don't think I'm good on that like on some
shit I ain't trying to
What I would
Like forever but I'm not oh yeah no I was
saying that I'm not in my feelings like I'm
straight that's that's the thing like I'm
just in my bag right now I'm just trying to
be on my shit and trying to find out who I
am as a man you know what I'm saying like
I'm trying to make sure that I am who I say
I am and
I understand that I understand that you know
and and
I get
Okay
Good things take time that the bridge
And you know well and that's the thing too
like that I'm definitely not rushing it and
I think it's going to be hard to find the
person that's for me because
I'm hella picky man she going to have she
going to haveMan.
She going to have himShe going to have him.
NoCuz I am depressed.
I amI just want to make somebody's life
better.
I don't have enough cash right now I can do
a day sleep when I get paidAnd I'm just
requested for my parents.
And I'll get it from thereAll right.
I have to pay for it
WhatI don't have the money.
If you want to give them something like me
for a thermostat well I got to go through
over explaining
Okay
Why no
No idea
Anyway
Hello I wouldn't mind Amazon getting a piece
of the cut long as they help him to make the
sales cuz like I say that's the hardest
aspect of everything is sending somebody out
to be like by this
Cuz like I sayAs bad as I want it that'll
never be me.
Or she really even financing right
It's all in the cost the business owners
never pay
AndI don't know.
All right stay safe